operators of the colonial pipeline are
warning
they may not return to full service for
several more days
thousands of gas stations up and down
the east coast and throughout the
southeast are running dry
this comes as the white house finally is
admitting
there is a gas shortage after all after
downplaying the crisis earlier this week
senator lindsey graham hitting the
response telling brian
this the two responses from the
president
biden and his spokesperson are unnerving
they're naive they're weak and they
don't show
an understanding of the problem
brian yeah uh yesterday right before we
went on the air
president biden says you'll be hearing
some news soon good news about the
pipeline
now we know the delay is going to be
slow uh but they're
they're eventually going to get back
online and then we find out according to
bloomberg
the colonial pipeline paid hackers five
million dollars so they paid the ransom
so they paid the ransom joe bryan
president biden must have known about it
i know it's a private company
but that's no reason for a wry smile
that's a very complicated
answer to a hostage situation i know
it's 13
i know 17 states are affected i know 45
percent of the diesel the oil the gas
the
jet fuel are affected but i the the ease
in which
they paid the ransom and they said that
it's the um
the encryption is so slow now that
they're getting online
they're still doing it manually i'm
wondering what message does it send you
took a super powers
the whole east coast to its knees and
for five million dollars
now can you imagine what else is
susceptible from refineries on down
a private company that affects our
infrastructure so substantially
we have to revisit all these things
privacy included
i get it but when it involves north
carolina having 85
of their gas stations shut down and the
gas now going up to 450 over in
california
now you're affecting every american